so today I'm going to show you a sort of
note-taking mini habit that I created
over the years that has allowed me to
retain most of the key lessons from the
books that I listen to the note taking
mini habit is essentially this see I
carry these little waterproof notebooks
with me and whenever I'm listening to a
book and I come across an aha moment
basically a moment where the gears in
your head click and something just makes
a whole lot of sense to you when that
happens I will put in some effort to
record that lesson down for example a
couple of weeks ago I was listening to
can't hurt me by David Goggins at the
gym and I came across an aha moment when
he talked about what he likes to call
the cookie jar method so I put down my
weights I paused the audiobook I pulled
out my little notebook and pen and I
wrote down cookie jar method and I
proceeded to write a short little
summary about what it was and after
doing that I rewinded the audio by a
couple of minutes just so I could listen
to that part again if you take a look at
this incident I'm putting in maybe 10 20
times more effort into digesting this
one piece of information and because of
that that lesson has stuck with me ever
since